the Joe Rogan experience that's crazy
because I remember hearing that as well
at crack babies were the thing we're all
worried about in the 80s oh my god wait
till the year 2000 all these crack
babies are 20 years old yeah I know yeah
where are they now maybe they're mumble
wrappers because you understand real rap
music definitely that's who I am
yeah let's kind of generation nas huge
nas fan Gang Starr love Gang Starr of
course biggie Tupac you know the the
classics you know I mean Big Daddy Kane
I love EPMD yeah just you know god
there's so many this it's just that era
it was like I mean there's a couple
errors and that I just listed but it is
lyrical like nas is my favorite I think
yeah as his lyrics they're so intricate
you know he's he the way he words things
you just go oh [ __ ] you know yeah I hear
his lyrics you just go oh like the king
of he's like the oh [ __ ] came yeah for
lyrics man he's the best
what was the was it rewind what was the
one where he played the whole song
backwards oh yeah talking about the
bullet going back into the gun all the
way through the entire story he starts
at the end and then backs up the story
maybe he had some [ __ ] classics I
think he's the best writer in all of
hip-hop yeah well you know it's just his
beats don't always hit me the right way
but he's got so many classics he's
earned like the right but but my big
thing because I did live in New York and
I was an East Coast you know like music
snob and like Biggie's clearly the best
ever I got for you fine enough you're
real cool G rap oh yeah he's I mean he's
the original he's the best he's my son
dispute
underground guy like people don't know
yeah if you list like some of the
Great's of all time
people don't say Kool G Rap can listen
to cock-blocking that is one of the best
[ __ ] songs this day I'll go listen
that song and I'll make me laugh yeah
that was yeah I mean that that like 80s
New York stuff is so so much of it Hill
streets so like so intellectual so
amazing wordplay yes but see when I came
to LA though everyone's like Tupac Tupac
Tupac and I was like I don't get it man
he's his flow is not that great you know
I just don't get it but but the more I
like listen to his lyrics the more I saw
he was more than just a rapper he was
like a cultural influence he was like a
political leader to a lot of people and
finally I'm like yes I get it he stood
for something and now like I just don't
hear Biggie the same way you know
because so many of his songs are about
you know partying and crime and stuff
and the bigger message of Tupac just
really won me over and then well I don't
think it's a competition but I know what
you're saying
I mean Tupac definitely had a different
vision but biggie you also have to
realize big he was like oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean Tupac was 25 I'm one of my
favorite videos of Biggie is biggy
standing on a street corner when he was
like 16 17 years old rappin you ever see
that I think I have with the lumberjack
stuff yeah he's got a [ __ ] eye I
think you might even have a piece of
paper in his hand huh
where's like reading the wrap-up or he's
got it like in case he [ __ ] up his
forget hello was so good even as a
little kid there's a [ __ ] kid man you
know he's like as good as any rapper
alive what can you find that can we play
that we'll get in trouble I'll play for
you after yeah well after the podcast
we'll play it and his breath control and
like wait sometimes I feel like you got
to be like yeah at almost something
amazing singer a rapper well comedians
to a lot of fat comedians like Patrice
O'Neal one of the greatest of all time
there was something about his girth when
he was on stage I was like power and
they like this whole thing is biggie
that's amazing yeah what's that smile
towel oh it might be a towel oh yeah
you're right die
yeah and just murdering it murdering it
everybody around them look at everybody
you know I saw this early Tupac videos
and heard early Tupac recordings and his
original style influence was actually
Fresh Prince of bel-air yes humph yeah
did you honor yeah yeah he was like in
the background of the humpty-hump dance
yeah yeah you can see ya know Tupac was
a dancer I mean and when he was young
which is really interesting when they
interview him he was like he wasn't
thugged-out at all like well he's the
son of two black panther as you know the
politics was always his thing what is
that from yeah that was like a solo
debut Wow yeah Digital Underground
whatever happened to them Humpty Humpty
I'm shocked gee he's yeah I'm still
around he's they were so good they had
great [ __ ] when you write a song that's
as profitable as the Humpty dance I
would imagine that kind of like saps
your need to do too much outs when
you're that set but I know he has though
he's he's the real deal
[Applause]